I'm going to read all of the opponent's attacks.
ーIt's
Kitani giving instructionsーme
[Applause]
me
wh
Team Shirado Hakutou Bunki When that Sugar opponent shows Undergate, it's not a good idea,
but apparently it's just a level of favoritism  I don't think so, I made a
mistake with Vega's admission I can say that it was only a goal, but
I got a ticket for Negara new with this.
I've
been told that I'm going to treat people like dogs like
Midia.
Who is more suitable for Megaro, Jade-
kun
or
me?
[Music]
It's not unreasonable to think so,
but what kind of traps should they set?
That's right, then it's true that you can't get the tooth tree or the flowers, but it's over, and
Matsu-chan's field is getting stronger in the middle of the game, so I've been watching it, so it
's not a problem
[music]